hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play paper the
second prototype now the developers of
this game were actually nice enough to
contact me and send me an early build of
their game because they said that my
videos had helped them out especially to
raise awareness for the game so I was
really grateful for that so I'm gonna
played then rip it apart in my review
and my critique and then come on in
horrible no it's actually I actually
really enjoyed this game and I can
already tell there's music that's been
added but anyway um as before you oh
wait no had not asked before I actually
read there's a story now you are an
ethereal floating warlock who is dead
and in purgatory and what you need to do
is defeat the three hell wardens hell
Lords in order to free your soul from
the constant grip of purgatory now I'm
gonna there was a constant run toggle
but it doesn't seem to be working but
anyway they may have changed up some
balance things because they said as was
commented before that it might have been
just really too big to hide you will you
be too hard
I remember you yeah ankle-biting
bastards I'm gonna blow you away with oh
whoa look at that look at I actually
have a hand that's so cool so that kind
of reaffirms the idea that I am a
warlock die you bastard
Oh Finn you oh well he died in two hits
that time instead of three that'll
actually help quite a bit
well health club those are health globes
I've learned and then I look at this and
then I stare into the abyss and then I
collect this wall whoa wow what happened
there but vision went up
why did my vision go up but anyway I
think I got it are not mistaken
uh-oh the music seems to be getting a
little more sinister either that it's
just the same as it was before I have to
comment that the music reminds me of
like one of those 90's horror movies
with like the monster creeping through
thousands like dun dun dun and then
you're like get out of the house get out
who's right well oh yeah I remember that
sound
I went the wrong way I almost went right
into it I think okay time to take this
seriously because I remember this game
is quite hard but I have played it
before so hopefully it'll ease up a bit
god dammit dammit I lost the light Oh
balls it's like that amnesic oh there it
is okay we got it all under control whoa
hey hey hey baby
ah that needs some work there okay
I just need to blow you guys blow you
skull bastards away Boosh key Oh baby
did you that was not good Oh why isn't
it doing the thing the vision thing was
like the coolest part what's like the
flashing images I guess that might have
been seizure inducing for some but still
it was really really creepy when that
happened I hope they didn't take that
out completely
harus yeah suck on that you demon
bastards oh oh it didn't do it alright
we got a long
there is not quite what I had in mind
but not bad Oh my hand turned blue whoa
triple kill or triple zap well this just
got a bit more interesting maybe it's
gonna get progressively more insane I
don't know hello can I have that please
thank you that is weird
ah come on zap whoa hi your face Sam
okay where was it
dun dun dun get out of the house mine go
away
get out of my way I don't need any of
your ball
I need a health thing that's for sure
but I don't need any year born there we
go
woah burski oh so much better
instantaneously better cuz I am just a
ghost tegu warlock oh you sons of
[ __ ]
suck on my lining Babu ski doesn't
really help because it kind of spreads
way too much too quickly that's what she
said oh okay I don't even know how that
fits whatever was sad stop staring at it
doctor whoa
stop looking up into the night sky and
just grab it Tabu ski oh I get it they
stop they stop following me after I find
the thing which is very useful because
before it was just like they would
pursue me and then as my vision stopped
it would be shot come on ah
and I their little ankle grabby Dinks
started to grabbed onto my dick that's
what they do that's why they got their
name the grabby dicks man
thumbs up bastards all right that's two
down we just need the last one which is
always the one that threw me there's a
blue orbs but I want the green rapid
fire whoa whoa hi okay was the light
where's my where's my weapon where's my
zappy do where'd my gun go I don't have
a gun anymore barely what why not I
don't have a fireball launcher I don't
know why but apparently I've lost all
rights to fireballs
I remember this get out of here
get that kid out of here Judy a tusky
okay this is easier to climb up I guess
Europe I remember I remember I don't
remember you being a giant son of a
[ __ ]
Oh oh that is a pile of dead babies I
haven't seen many piles of dead babies
in my time but that is definitely the
Pylea stuff Wow god dammit I ran right
into him again Raj
God isn't it oh he's just not he's not
just screaming he's actually saying
words hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey
whoa the hell no I'm gonna die again
well this is exactly the problem I ran
into before that's exactly the same
problem now why in the world was I
unable to shoot fireballs when there
were the most fireballs of any time why
was that a thing why was that a thing
yeah alright let's try this one more
time but I'm only gonna do it once more
oh I'm gonna get it I'm gonna activate
maximum silliness mode you know did you
know that markiplier has like gears like
like you'd lose serious mode there's
trihard mode and then there's silly mode
and then there's Maximum Overdrive silly
mode so that's what we're gonna go to
Lincoln Clank like yeah alright let's go
back into it guys shooting fireballs out
of my dick
alright where to go there did oh come on
I want to get to this what are you gonna
do grab on to the green balls there were
green green balls before it was like
they gave me balls they gave me so many
balls before the third one I think there
were just tons of them and then my
fireball like right there no it came
back after I did that one but I mean
before it took away my balls how dare I
dare it this was seated
shut up bastards Wow
he'll that's right get back down there
oh yeah alright so now that we got the
son of a [ __ ] after us all we need to
do is the same as before
boy I don't know why there's being
stupid cuz that's what they be just
stupid oh well whatever it's not like I
needed the first and second ones are
actually easier than they were before I
think least a little bit mm-hmm maybe
maybe maybe not
I'm not sure maybe I'm just talking
about but cuz I don't even know what I'm
talking about anymore
your other than the other than the music
and the slight change in how the screen
reacts when the monsters are nearby and
when you're getting the items I can't
really tell how much is different in the
game
but I mean this is just like the
beginning of the game they are trying to
build after this so this is just like
the introductory level I believe wanna
give me tiny I know you seem to be
screaming about your eternal damnation
in pain
well I got a meeting back on the earth
wonder what kind of warlock I was kind
of world do I go back to maybe that's
the thing maybe after I do this like
I'll go back to my own world and then
just like you know that'll be it I just
go do my thing okay hey I was about to
shoot a fireball No got the greenie but
didn't do anything the Blooey look at
that I can swap between the green and
the blue but that's about it
and then before it took it away
completely so let's give this another
try now I got three balls now you'll
never stand a chance I'm the greatest
error was you you know you know okay
watch this I'm not even gonna move my
mouse it's awesome oh look it up hey how
about you brush and how much you wish
that's right that's what I thought like
the shotgun of spells Oh
mean oh let's don't look good for
markiplier this looks like the end for
us little kitties oh no we're okay that
tone that tone that it screams in my
ears is still rather annoying Levinsky
he's gotta kill him on the way I guess I
don't know there was uh there was a
readme file in the UH and the thing that
said like read this if you're a giant
noob and can't beat the game and I got a
feeling like that
hey wait a minute that's a meant for me
that meant for me yeah god damn it yeah
whoo double kill we get a health thingy
we dodged the screamer bastard why do
you put your hand away you kinda need
your hand out you know when there's
demons all around the monsters appear
Kotori are still trying to get you yeah
that's right Jeff off
yeah now I'm actually telling him doing
good and stuff now maybe it was a bug
that it took away my hand I still got my
hand right here I'm Scott okay see oh no
I still have it why didn't you take it
away before what happened okay whatever
runs I have it now okay so it's just a
bug that it got taken away I guess I
don't know I don't even know I don't
even know we still have it okay I just
definite like this I got a bad feeling
about this one boy I sure hope there
aren't any pile of dead babies over here
also still that horror music is going on
Thun Thun Thun Thun being very careful
about this or not even getting up I
can't I got this one ledge Oh dad let me
out the ledge I'm not joking around I
can't get up this ledge let me have the
latch oh god they're all sorry I had to
take a running jump at it
oh okay No Wow BAP okay no oh come on I
saw the pile of dead babies yeah yeah
dead babies we're back like when dead
baby jokes were like the biggest thing
every like do when I was in junior high
like everyone told that baby jokes just
gladly uh-huh
no it's not it's not morbid it's not
real gems Tony Joe no okay so I'm trying
to dodge this guy what why why why is
that tree so scary that tree who's not
scary took me a second to realize that
the tree was screaming at me where was
the life
I got damn it he's right there tap pause
no get off of me I'm gonna blame you
slam your big ancient oh I'm out of
balls I saw the light Oh
saw the light damn it get off a might
get off of my get off of me oh my is
about yellow ski I get it so I only have
a certain stockpile of ammo Hey look
there's more balls
all right Oh mouse key oh okay yeah stop
looking at it I'm looking at it and get
it get it get it I said get it oh it's
up here its crown I sound like amethyst
guy what the hell did it go that stop
gimme Oh you if you ask me over with
your mouse [ __ ] damn terrain I am going
to oh if I if I had died there I would
have been so upset I would have been
beyond angry I would have raged an
unending rage and never want to
recommend this game to anyone
there we go so uh so what about that so
so what about that so what about that oh
oh well did I get my eternal reward -
what's all this then I never saw the
ending I know the yamimash actually
managed to beat it I don't know how but
he did I tried for like an hour and it
didn't do jack what the
well I don't look good lavishing some
good things in my time but that looks
the least good iasts I'm just gonna say
that right now Oh what the hell get away
from me get away from me no no this is
no ankle crabbers all I gotta do is keep
runnin a yeah get away from me
oh you're twisty no no no no no no no no
no no no and don't weren't any new think
that's weird cuz the music is almost
cheerful that glenda like I'm on an
adventure down this wooden plank lay off
my way into what some sort of staircase
that's appearing in the distance over
here
am i is sis's linen is stairway pop down
stop looking at him you're killing me oh
oh okay well that was a thing apparently
oh I can actually run backwards that's
cool
wish I had known that earlier but uh
Hinnom hi Mina stairway to heaven stay
away - hello
I got one guy in the Guitar Center blew
me ma'am where am i burning my bear bear
yeah ow
I torque my shoulder I don't know what
happened yeah it hurts so bad don't know
what happened ow okay
it all fades to black
there we go I made it to the end
I guess tada
that's it um I really don't know what
was all that different between the first
and the second one umm but yeah there is
gonna be a full game I got this early
because um they were nice enough to give
it to me before people got the IndieGoGo
campaign so you can see the link there
the link in the description and the game
crashes tags it out of it that's yeah
it's real classy but um so yeah well
it's not a bad game it's actually a
really cool game in a rumor the first
time I played it I really had no idea
what's going on I really am disappointed
that they took away the flashing images
because that was a really cool mechanic
if they had balanced it out a bit more
so that you know everything stopped when
you got the flashing things because that
was really cool I'm kind of sad that
they took it out because that was one of
those most nerve-wracking things about
it so I don't know why it was gone why
whatever oh whatever
so anyway links in the description below
click it do whatever you want with it
marry it I don't care what you want so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video hello
loose damn chair
eat my mouth
my lord call about
sounds about right guy
mud
plagued by now
living three dreams